it's Independence Day so let's talk
about what's going on in America freedom
is under attack in your state dictator
Ron DeSantis incredibly lets you walk
around without masks that Tyrant allows
your kids to go to school during the
pandemic year two or four or who the
hell knows I urge you living in Florida
to join the fight or join us in
California where we'll take the money
you earn and give it to people who don't
work visit San Francisco where you can
walk through human feces if you're lucky
you might step on a syringe check out
Los Angeles where gas is so expensive
your kids only need to skip a meal or
two or ten to afford it California where
Freedom means lockdowns for you well I
go to the places you can't afford don't
let them take your freedom come to
California where we'll take it along
with your money
foreign
what up yo I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Reuben report it is September 8th 2022
and that cold open there that was my
buddy Trey Ray Dell former Floridian
Congressman uh Trey Ray Dell uh who
covered the uh the Southwest portion of
Florida uh he put up that video about
six weeks ago I I just thought I saw it
again this morning it bumped up in my
feed somehow and I thought it would sort
of be perfect for today because uh
California is basically enrolling
blackouts right now because of that
ridiculous man Gavin Newsom and his
ridiculous policies and here in the Free
State of Florida uh it's nice and chilly
in the studio we normally keep it at 66
which you know you got to keep a studio
chilled so that you're not sweating so
you're not getting the shine on your
face it also kind of keeps me and the
team awake David Letterman little
Insider TV knowledge for you David
Letterman for the 30 years that he did
his show used to keep that studio as
cold as you could possibly get because
you won especially during comedy you
want people to be awake can alert like
if it gets warm in there people start
going like this and wiping the brow and
everything people start falling asleep
and not paying attention but Gavin
Newsom wants people in California right
now to keep their thermostats above 78
degrees he even put out a video uh
telling people to do that and he was
wearing a fleece while indoors so uh you
think that maybe he's not going to
follow that you think that maybe Nancy
Pelosi is not going to follow that point
being people I love Florida how about
that uh we're going to do a
reubenreport.locals.com q a for you
today and it is totally uncensored as
always but first I wanted to talk to you
guys about some I saw a couple we're
just going to catch up on a few little
covid related things because look I get
it covet has nothing to do with my life
it probably has nothing to do with your
life and you can take whatever
precautions you still want but there is
a set of people whether it is Justin
Trudeau who I'm going to focus on today
up in Canada who is just he is the Gavin
Newsom of Canada right you talk about
authoritarian these shell people they
look a certain way and they speak a
certain way and that's how they've
become successful but they don't stand
for their people or for Freedom or
anything like that he put out a video
yesterday that's absolutely chilling
then we've got this ridiculous fouchy
guy and a couple other coveted Maniacs
that we're just gonna we're gonna mock
appropriately and then move on uh and
then I'll get to some questions before
we do all that let me talk to you guys
about Patriot Supply friends would you
like to save a lot of money while
getting prepared for the coming food
shortages they're probably on the way
especially if you're in California uh go
to prepare with reuben.com prepare with
reuben.com and you'll save 250 on a
three-month emergency food kit from my
Patriot Supply they're the nation's
largest preparedness company with
millions of satisfied customers but
right now they've cut their prices to
the lowest in three years they're
temporarily charging less so they can
help Americans more they know it's time
to get everyone prepared for what's
coming so go to prepare with reuben.com
and save 250 bucks on off a three-month
emergency food kit that's packed with a
wide variety of delicious meals be sure
to get one kit for each member of your
family at this price you can afford to
they're in stock and ship fast with free
delivery your order will arrive in
unmarked boxes for your privacy don't
wait the sale ends soon and might not be
repeated go to prepare with reuben.com
right now prepare with reuben.com and
now back to me okay
so Justin Trudeau is the prime minister
up in Canada uh frankly I'd rather refer
to him as a dictator he has he got in
with like less than 30 percent of the
vote we know that he's locked his people
down he was forcing people to get
injected he did not let non-vaccinated
people leave the country via airplane he
has just done almost everything
absolutely wrong he threatened uh the
truckers who were peacefully protesting
with jail time and freezing bank
accounts he's just terrible he's just
terrible uh well he uh is still big on
the vaccine thing and he's threatening
people once again yesterday here we go
kovid's not done with us yet we might
want to be done with it but it's still
around and yes we have a lot more tools
a lot more understanding a lot more
knowledge on how to keep ourselves and
our loved ones safe that have allowed us
to get back to regular life in a lot of
ways for a whole bunch of people there
is a real risk of another serious wave
of covet one of the best things we can
do
to prevent that way of prevent the
pressure on our Health Care Systems
prevent provinces from having to take
decisions around restrictions and
mandates
is to ensure that everyone is up to date
in their vaccinations we have new
vaccines coming out this month
that are tailored against Omicron that
will provide better protection and
everyone should get out and get
vaccinated if we are able to hit that 80
85 90 of Canadians up to date in their
vaccinations will have a much better
winter with much less need for the kinds
of restrictions and rules that were so
problematic for everyone over the past
years
man you know how I have to apologize to
you guys when I show clips of The View
it's like I sort of feel like I have to
apologize when I show clips of Trudeau
he's so inauthentic that way of speaking
sort of I'm not really a human and I'm
trying to pretend I'm a human so this is
I do it and I have nice socks and my
shirt fits and that's what I'm doing uh
now first off there's just so much
nonsense there we have more information
now blah blah blah none of the stuff
that he did in the first place was based
on any factual information it was based
on can we exert government power over
you the citizens and how far can we push
you before you push back and then
finally when you do push back say the
truckers we're going to push even
further
um he then wants 80 to 90 percent of
people to be vaccinated so that they
won't have to do the same stuff that
didn't work last time and he's also
saying that this new vaccine will really
deal with the Omicron variant the
Omicron variant which I got which almost
everyone got remember when that went
bananas here in the United States at
least right around Christmas time it was
right actually when I moved to Florida
though I got it in LA I know exactly
where I got it
um
it was it was the flu my legs hurt for a
few days that's it and I'm not vaxxed
and I'm never getting vaxxed uh and you
as a government Authority have no right
to tell anyone what to do with their
bodies which is exactly what you guys
would say if perhaps we were talking
about abortion so he's just a fraud he's
trying to scare people again and they
want you to be injected with stuff even
though they don't know if it really does
anything and they'll do that all under
the guise of if you don't do that thing
uh well we're also going to lock you
down again well uh here in the United
States Anthony fauci who I guess is
finally stepping down and who should be
shamed and embarrassed to ever show his
face anywhere in public ever again he's
now realizing because he told us
originally that the vaccines work and
you're not going to get and transmit
covid that's what Joe Biden also said
that they don't really work as promised
and since they don't really work but you
know we kind of want the drug companies
to make money how about we uh just give
you one every year
it is becoming increasingly clear that
looking forward with the covid-19
pandemic
in the absence of a dramatically
different variant
we likely are moving towards a path
with a vaccination Cadence similar to
that of the annual influenza vaccine
with annual updated covid-19 shots
matched to the currently circulating
strains for most of the population
yeah no no I'm not going to do it you're
going to do it no you no you no okay
what are you gonna do you're gonna come
and get us uh buffoon absolute buffoon
the vaccines did not work as promised do
not work as promised he doesn't even
know if you get them every year how long
they will work complete nonsense and
then just one more thing on this I don't
want to dwell on covet that often but I
think every now and again we just gotta
show these little blip moments where you
just see that they just keep moving on
this stuff right so you can live your
life you can ignore all of it but there
is this machine version of it that's
just passing through that's convincing
people that they still have to listen to
these people and do all this stuff and
and be scared and Afraid and all of that
this is covid response coordinator
Ashish
saying the goal is not to get back to
normal but something else perhaps
I've heard secretary Cardona say this
over and over again you know people do
talk about going back to normal and I've
heard Mr secretary uh say you know
normal wasn't working out so well
forever for some people and so the goal
in my mind is not to go back to normal
the goal is to build a very different
New Normal that has Equity much more at
the heart of it
yeah well then every now and again they
tell you the quiet part right uh no more
old world I thought that old world was
pretty good you remember that old world
it was a hell of a lot better than this
yeah uh well they want a new world and
they want Equity to be part of it when
you say you want equity in health that
is the most Anti I would say Hippocratic
o thing that you could possibly say
because what you're saying is we want
Equity now that means that everyone
based on theirs because these people
love skin color and gender and sexuality
everyone across the board will get the
same amount of covid and we'll have the
same amount of debts and all that stuff
you know what that means basically uh it
means that what they want in essence is
more dead white people that really is
the end result of what they want I have
no doubt Media Matters is going to clip
this and post it but that is what they
want when they say want equity in health
care uh and by the way that's not even
an exaggeration because we know that
cities in the United States I believe
Seattle did it and a couple others were
giving vaccines
based on skin color right and eventually
they'll do it based on sexuality and
everything else whether the vaccines
work or not is a moot point but you get
this is them ushering in their great
reset it's ushering in their new world I
just don't want anything to do with it I
got one more on fauci because I saw this
this morning
um and it's a it's a side by side of
fauci on how he decides what we should
be doing when it comes to certain things
like Hydro hcq versus uh what it comes
to vaccines I mean this is really
extraordinary watches when I do see a
randomized placebo-controlled trial that
looks at any aspect of
hydroxychloroquine either early Study
middle study or late if that's
randomized placebo-controlled trial
shows efficacy I would be the first one
to admit it and to promote it so I just
have to go with the data I don't have
any horse in the game one way or the
other it hasn't been proven in a
clinical trial because we don't have
time to do a clinical trial because we
need to get the vaccine out now
that second video that you saw there
that's from a day or two ago so do you
see that what he just did there when it
was hcq and people were saying hey this
might work this might prevent covid or
might lessen the symptoms he needed way
more data guys we need studies we need
data early studies late studies you got
to throw me something give me some
papers on the desk to look at now that
it's oh maybe it'll be annual vaccines
for you guys we gotta Rush this [ __ ] out
people we can't look at the data we
don't have time for paper I could get a
paper cut
they are just absolutely awful I I just
cannot believe that anyone thinks that
Anthony fauci the highest paid person in
the federal government 420
000 a year on top of I think he's going
to make that salary continually while he
retires and God knows how much money
he's made through all of the vaccine
stuff and everything else and all of the
Shady deals and what information he gave
to people related to drug companies like
he just reeks of all of those things I
am the science no I I am the lies that's
what he really is anyway I just wanted
to get through a little bit of that
let's not freak out about covid uh oh
and the White House also has this new
monkey pox advisor that actually I'm
pretty sure is spreading monkey pox but
that's a whole other story let's talk
about real estate agents I trust and
then get to the questions uh you guys
know that buying or selling a home is
already one of the most stressful things
you can do and it can be 10 times worse
if you're not working with the right
agent our homes are often our biggest
investment which of course is a ton of
responsibility and you need an agent who
takes that seriously which is why I
recommend real estate agents I trust
they work with only the best agents in
every Market they do their homework
talking to every agent before inviting
them to join their Network and here's a
big one they only work with full-time
Pros no part-time or inexperienced
agents their team makes the introduction
and follows you through the buying or
selling process to make sure that you're
satisfied the agents they work with have
long track records they're the best
sellers in their field they're part of
this audience they share your values and
they're almost anywhere you want to go
just go over to real estate agents I
trust.com today give them some info
they'll contact you make an intro to
their preferred agent and then you will
move to Florida and live happily ever
after okay reubenreport.locals.com
Community Q a here we go it's a good mix
today Big Poppy
is that David Ortiz former Red Sox star
David Ortiz uh in the banana world uh
how are you and David going to Shield
the two boys from all the Meshuggah
great word little Yiddish to tighten up
the show today
um how are we going to do it I mean
we've had some talks about that stuff
like especially related to schools and
stuff like you know Florida happens to
have particularly good Public Schools
right this was partly why Ron DeSantis
was doing uh the whole remember don't
say gay he was trying to push the
nonsense out of the schools because it
was even leaking into schools here and
there's something funny about the uh the
Florida public school situation because
it used to be mocked constantly Florida
was always mocked I remember when I was
growing up Florida was mocked I grew up
in Suburban New York area outside of New
York City where we had great schools and
my my uh my high school was a blue
ribbon school you know they they put tax
money to education and it worked I don't
know if it works anymore but Florida
because there was no state income tax
everyone thought oh they don't fund
School schools the schools are horrible
blah blah blah we know that's just not
the case right now Florida has some of
the best schools in the country Public
Schools I'm talking about they have
great private schools too I can't
imagine
partly also because of me being a public
figure that will send our kids to public
school maybe private school you know
we've talked a little bit about
homeschooling or pod schooling you know
we've got a couple year window on this
um but I will not I mean I can tell you
as a father for for just a month so far
like when you're holding that kid and
you realize you have this precious
innocent
true thing that you're responsible for
what at some level for a certain period
of time you're responsible for what
information will will enter them what
beliefs will enter them what worldview
will enter them well I'm going to do
everything that I possibly can do and
David as well to make sure that the
right ideas get in them and I don't I
would that's the thing about when you
hear about these teachers that want to
talk to someone else's kids someone
else's five-year-old about sex or gender
or race or any of this stuff infect them
with these crazy ideas and that parents
willfully do it or think that it's the
good thing to do or they tell these kids
you know we want to talk to you about
gender affirmation you know they always
say that the surgeries these are gender
affirming care but but even that it's a
flip on reality it's not gender
affirming here if you're chopping off
someone's genitals it's gender
unaffirming care that doesn't that isn't
to say that someone can't live as a
trans obviously but it's not affirming
their gender it's unaffirming their
gender they're their gender boy girl
when we went to the hospital baby came
out it's a boy okay they didn't say it's
whatever you want it to be so we got
work to do on that it's a good question
and and uh I'll try to be as open and
honest about it with you guys as
possible uh Nick says while you were
gone this August I decided to re-watch
your first direct messages I noticed
that your demeanor and voice have
changed from being more playful to more
professional now do you think that's due
to fatherhood or becoming Florida man
boy you know my general sort of outlook
on this show is I try to do it in a in a
fun way in a somewhat light way and some
humor and silliness and you know with
some degree of smile on my face when
possible despite dealing often with a
lot of nonsense but then at the same
time
you know as the mainstream media has
lied more and more I guess I do feel a
certain degree of pressure to do it a
little more professionally all the time
so I don't know I don't know I mean I
can tell you this when when we do a show
that I know I'm like man like you know
we cold close it and then we're all
sitting here doing the recap for a few
minutes like the shows that make me the
happiest are the ones that are the
funniest for sure if these guys are
laughing and I know I hit a couple
things like to me that's like the most
fun for me and the most valuable for me
because if I can make you laugh about
politics
um well then hopefully like there's a
reason there's a reason to watch this
there's a million other shows you could
turn on a million other shows whether
it's on cable news or whether it's on
YouTube or whatever to see people
ranting and crazed about politics and
everything else so I'm trying to do just
sort of the right blend of of lightness
and humor and seriousness but truth be
told like I don't think about it that
much like we set up a show and then I do
it and it's not scripted and sometimes
times it's going to be funnier and
sometimes it's going to be more serious
and all that stuff Shelley says any bets
on how long Korean Jean-Pierre is going
to last it has to be very painful lying
all day and every day plus she's so
stupid it's got to be quite a strain
trying to think of dumb stuff to fit the
narrative I mean it's really incredible
what happened to this woman you guys
know I mean for a year I don't know that
anyone mocked uh Jen saki Jen saki more
than I did right like she was so
horrible and you could see it on her
face the pain of lying all the time and
she was just you know I'll Circle back
and couldn't say anything true right
what was my line on her always it was it
if you asked her what her favorite color
was she would say four like the woman
simply could not say something true and
then they bring in Korean Jean-Pierre
and she is absolutely unqualified
they made it clear that the reason they
brought her in was because she was a
black lesbian they that's what they
believe is the most important thing it's
not your qualifications or your
competence it is do you check this box
does your skin color look like this does
your sexuality look like this that's
enough to get the gig and this is across
the entire Administration she's horrible
I mean she is a absolutely horrible
press secretary she is not only a
horrible press secretary but she's the
easiest job in the world because if it
wasn't for Peter Ducey there's no one in
there that's asking her any difficult
questions right but she can't answer
anything honestly she mispronounces
things constantly she barely knows what
she's talking about she's smug and
dismissive uh you know just the other
day they were asking her about Peter
Ducey of course was asking her hey you
know you used to be uh for uh talking
about elections that are illegitimate
you call Donald Trump's election
illegitimate and you sort of implied
that they stole the election in in
Georgia from Stacey Abrams well Allah
and like she has nothing to say so she
just laughs oh that's just ridiculous
and just laughs it off so uh how long
will they go with her they'll probably
ride her out till the end of this thing
because she has the she has the force
field of protection that only black
lesbianism can provide there's a
sentence I've never said before uh
Island that says hello Dave what are
your future endeavors professionally do
you have plans late laid out at all
well look the big thing on the horizon
for me right now is obviously we took
locals and it was just an idea that I
had it was like can we build a
subscription model for us and see what
happens and then we were like boy it
kind of works and then we started you
know offering it up to other people and
then the rumble people approached and
now we're one company uh and there's
just like so much energy right there
because we're not going to censor People
based on political beliefs and it's like
the machine is so there's so much energy
going towards Rumble and locals right
now uh and although I don't own the
company anymore I am an advisor to the
company and and it's me and Dan bongino
mainly are the sort of public-facing
people to discuss so when there's issues
around speech or around
hate speech or some of this other stuff
we can be out there talking about how
we're making the policies and we're
working with uh we're working with the
lawyers and all the people to to work
through all of that stuff and it's not
nothing on top of the technological
issues to deal with so that's sort of
the tech part of my life I'll tell you
one thing that I'm really interested in
that I've I haven't really done much of
um well I certainly haven't done any at
a work level I've done some probably I'm
really interested maybe in getting into
some like real estate or like building I
there's so much construction going on
here in Florida and I love watching
houses go up we did a bunch of
construction here at the house and
picking finishes and windows and colors
and wood and floors and marble and like
all of the stuff and I really do think
it's fun and and cool David's
particularly good at it so I could I
think maybe we could spin off some other
business uh and also David's working on
his cookbook which now with one baby and
now another baby coming it's getting
hard so we were thinking of maybe
combining that into one cookbook for
everybody to get it out a little bit
faster so we shall see mama bear says
hey Dave what are some of the nicknames
you've been calling baby Justin just
curious I had several for each of mine
and they were in no relation to their
actual names you know it's funny I uh
because I do this during the day and I'm
often in the studio and everything else
the way the mornings have gone and if
you're in locals that's where I've been
posting pictures of Justin I'm not
really posting them uh publicly anywhere
um but I I wake up early
um I sit with him uh sometimes feed him
depending on where his sleep schedule is
at but that's how I'm starting my
morning these days for at least a half
hour and I have to tell you it's much
better than being on Twitter uh and it's
a nice way to like just kind of get a
little perspective in the morning and
and just kind of it's almost like I mean
for any of you that have a newborn or
have had a newborn it's like it's like a
drug in a way like because you see this
this human that is a blank canvas and
it's like it's your responsibility as I
said earlier to like fill them with the
right things and it's like what an
incredible opportunity that is and if
that doesn't you know make you better I
don't know what possibly would so it's
been a great way to start the day I do a
lot of funny accents with him and silly
voices and a lot of that kind of stuff
um mostly if I was to repeat those those
accents on air right now people would be
calling me racist but they're not racist
they're just funny accents
um and I like make up languages and all
sorts of stuff
um I call him Mr burrito often because
when they wrap them up in the swaddle I
don't do the swaddle I can't figure it
out it's very confusing to me Daphne you
doing the swaddle you do the swaddle all
right so maybe Daphne's going to give me
some swaddle tips but I've tried we have
all these big you know about the swaddle
it's basically a a sheet that you wrap
the child up in almost like you're
sending them to a mental institution so
that they can't you know you're putting
them in a padded cell they're locked in
this thing and then they look like a
little burrito so I call him Mr burrito
and uh oh and then in the morning I
usually start with him upstairs because
we have a nice window up there and then
I bring him down and then David's
usually downstairs making coffee or
something and I said present the child
it's like Simba and I hold him up and
Clyde jumps up and down music starts
playing it's the whole thing Kelly says
do you really think people are turning
out to vote based mostly on abortion I
don't understand the change in the polls
well other than their left leaning
so I guess a couple of polls have come
out lately with the implication that
maybe it's not going to be the crazy red
wave that everyone's anticipating first
off I don't put that much stock into
these polls we often find that they are
widely and wildly skewed depending on
who they're coming from so I wouldn't
get too lost in that I would say number
one you got to keep your eye on the ball
even here in Florida where it's like Ron
DeSantis is obviously going to win this
guy Charlie Crist is just a nothing in a
suit and and the idea that you could
live in a place like Florida and not
realize why it is such a great place and
who are the people that that fought for
that is just is just nonsense but we
also know that you know Florida now has
something like a 300 000 Surplus in
registered Republicans than Democrats
when DeSantis got in I think it was down
by about 50 Grand so it's pretty
incredible what's happening here but to
talk about it at a more wide level the
abortion thing I think mostly and the
reason you're asking the question is the
media because the media are Democrats
and everything that's mainstream dream
are Democrats they are upset about the
abortion situation and they they are
using that to fire up people to vote now
there are a certain amount of people who
will vote on abortion everything being
equal at least from where I sit your
even whether you're solidly pro-life or
solidly pro-choice abortion in and of
itself shouldn't necessarily be I can't
speak to everybody else I'll speak for
myself it's not in my let's say top five
things that I would vote on say relative
to the economy or policing or Borders or
things like that things that things that
I think the state should solidly be
involved in and that they're if you
elect the right people they can guide
you properly in those things and if you
look at the country two years after
covet it's like what were the things we
that we really suddenly realized were
important for governments to do or not
do abortion because it is more about
personal responsibility of the woman and
the man and what decisions people want
to make after being pregnant and
everything else for me it's a little bit
lower that's not to dismiss the
importance of life and all those things
I don't know which way it's going to
push people because I think you can
argue it either way that the the people
who are upset about the Roe v Wade thing
that maybe a certain set of of younger
women will get out and vote in ways that
they wouldn't have otherwise because
nobody really likes Joe Biden so they
wouldn't have been fired up in a midterm
but they have a little extra juice but I
think there's another counter argument
would be that Republicans who maybe were
going to be a little bit complacent they
see the craziness coming from left and
they will vote more so I don't know that
there's a way to really calculate that
properly Mark says
Dave how did you and David decide on the
name Justin please confirm that it is in
no way related to the douchebag your
words not mine we have as prime minister
here in Canada no and we were worried
about this I thought if we named the
child Justin people were going to say
but what about Justin Trudeau uh as some
of you know I said this on a lot of the
tour stops I wanted there was a huge
part of me that wanted to name the kid
Brandon because I just thought like
everywhere he goes people are going to
say let's go Brandon he'll become like
Forrest Gump it'll be amazing uh but the
reason that we went with Justin is that
David's parents had a first child who uh
unfortunately uh passed away when he was
about six months old had a heart
condition uh so would have been our
Justin's Uncle uh David's parents went
on to have he's the third of three
children that are are still here has so
Justin has on that side a great uncle
and a great aunt
um and so it was very obvious for us
it's the first grandchild on David's
side of the family so it was I think for
Dave its parents was was very powerful
and uh we have I think we've basically
settled on a name for number two
um and also we happen to have liked the
name Justin like it really did work we
have you know everyone when you're
having kids you got a list of names you
like one person likes these names one
person likes these names you hopefully
have a couple that you both like and you
can and you can figure it out uh okay we
got a couple more questions let me just
talk to you guys about the blaze real
quick uh as you know I was gone in
August Larry Elder gave me a rundown of
all that happened when I was away and it
was a ton was I surprised to hear that
Zuckerberg helped the FBI aka the
government manage the hunter Biden
laptop story no not really were you was
I surprised to hear that Gavin Newsom is
continuing to destroy California with
near laughable measures no not really
for you think msnb think of MSNBC like
California and Blaze TV like Florida
Texas you'd have to be crazy to believe
California will suddenly see and admit
to the era of their ways for the same
reason you'd have to be crazy to think
that MSNBC will ever be fair and Report
the news without a rabid left-wing
agenda that's why Blaze TV matters it's
the network for Americans who actually
love the country is founded it's where
people can say what needs to be said
without fear of censorship you know how
strongly I believe in free speech will
Blaze TV supports Free Speech the way
the founders intended so this week and
this week only Blaze TV is offering
twenty dollars off the first year of a
blaze TV subscription we're heading into
the midterms you're going to want news
from a network that isn't run by
democrats or the spouses of Democrats
use promo code Reuben 20 for 20 off your
first year subscription to Blaze TV it's
time to normalize Free Speech Elizabeth
says do you think Iran DeSantis Tulsi
gabbard ticket
in 2024 is a winning presidential ticket
do you think Tulsi would run with Ron uh
and lastly can you have Tulsi on the
show again uh we'll absolutely have
Tulsi on the show again and I will
gladly ask her that uh Chelsea and I
become friends uh off camera as well and
she's she's just really a decent
thoughtful person I think as I've said
before about Tulsi before she has to
decide and she's no longer in Congress
right this was a Democrat congresswoman
she by the way was the last Democrat who
stayed in the running when they handed
it to Biden and everybody got out and
they cut their deals so that AP would be
Transportation secretary and everyone
got what they needed from Biden she
stayed in it so the machine was really
not happy with her Hillary Clinton
literally called her a Russian asset
remember that so the machine hates her
the machine does not like Ron DeSantis
so there are certain League common cause
there
um I think Tulsi has to figure out like
if she wants to be in politics first I
can't speak for her so I don't know that
she even wants to go back into politics
you know she guest hosted Tucker Carlson
while I was off the grid that's
interesting so maybe she wants to go
into broadcasting a little bit more but
I think that the two of them it is it's
the right idea so I don't have to
explain why I like Ron DeSantis I think
you guys get it but then you have a
female so you get some of the identity
politics points but you get what at that
point would be considered a former
Democrat a moderate someone that 20
years ago almost every Democrat would
agree with on everything who will be
called all of the worst things in the
book right she will be they will trash
her and try to take her out and Destroy
her and all of those things
um but I think it potentially could be a
winning ticket I mean this all goes to
whether DeSantis is going to run or not
where Trump is going to be DeSantis
still has a a governor race here in
Florida that he's got to mop up on which
I think he will so
um we shall see but I but look I would
gladly I can say that very plainly I
would gladly support that ticket uh
Shannon says when are you going to be on
Bill Maher really looking forward to
this how are you feeling about it I
truly hope you can help encourage him to
finally swallow the red pill love your
show as always and so happy you're back
so I am doing Bill Maher's podcast this
is his he started a podcast about six
months ago this is his two hour
supposedly unfiltered uncensored
conversations that he has with people
it's called Club random they do it from
his house so I am going back to Los
Angeles I'm flying to L.A people
Phoenix you're coming too how do you
feel about that
like that we are going to La uh two
hours and I'm going to sit down with
Bill uh they've told me they don't want
it to be purely political in nature
right because he's trying to do
something a little bit different than
real time on there so look I'm open to
talking about anything and everything I
will if it presents itself nudge him the
ways that I've tried to nudge him here I
hope that when it ends that he thinks
that I'm someone that is saying
something worthwhile and whether we
agree or not it was a it was a valuable
conversation but I'm gonna try I I
really am going to try I mean Bill why
are you a Democrat at this point why do
you do you honestly believe that all the
religious people are crazy what big
government policies do you believe in
maybe I'm tipping off a little too much
if his producers are watching but I'm
not trying to get him either you know
what I mean like I want to have that
battle when I started doing stand-up in
98 like it was one of my dreams was to
be on Politically Incorrect those of you
of a certain age don't even remember
Politically Incorrect that was his show
on ABC for about 20 years before he got
real real time on HBO which eventually
was canceled basically because of some
remarks he made about 9 11 that were
totally misconstrued by the media
so there's a lot to talk about what's
interesting also is that you know most
of the people that have been on there
have been like real close friends of his
he said Adam Carolla on there who's a
good buddy of his he's had William
Shatner he's had more you know sort of
traditional celebrity types so maybe
they're trying to shift the show a
little bit by having somebody like me on
there he's had Jay Leno on Jimmy Kimmel
so obviously it's going to be a
different situation uh with a guy like
me so so we shall see and and then look
I'd still do the other show I'd still do
real time they've canceled me on there a
couple times uh but I'm not interested
in like creating a fight about this what
I'm interested in is hey you were the
standard bearer of liberalism in America
for 20 years liberalism atheism that
that purely secular thing it seems to
have crumbled you seem to recognize that
I'm not sure why you would be wildly
against a guy like Rand Paul or even a
guy like Ted Cruz would you vote for a
guy like Ron DeSantis you shot your last
HBO special a couple months ago here in
Florida you're always talking about how
good Florida is is
let's get you to the promised land man
and I'll buy a bag of weed after
whatever you want snow baby says you
have mentioned previously that you
weren't too interested in having kids it
was something David wanted now that you
have your first baby how have things
changed do you feel differently
connected it's not so bad enjoy it uh
the first two weeks were the hardest for
me do you guys feel like you're ready
for baby number two next month wishing
you all the best so I said to Connor
this morning it's like it's crazy that
we're gonna have another baby in like a
couple weeks like the baby could come at
any point this boy like it's supposed to
come middle of October but you know
we're closing in
um but yeah I mean I've sort of
explained it already like I do I feel
different I feel a different way to the
world I've always felt a certain way to
the World on me it's why I do this I
feel a certain world weariness or
something it's why I try to
why I've spent these years trying to
make the world a little bit of a better
place hopefully sometimes I've done it
well sometimes probably not so well but
now I feel this double pressure it's
like if I was gone tomorrow it's like
hopefully I did something so that this
kid has a chance right like the
incredible chance you know I wrote about
it in the first book it's like my family
coming to America was mostly my great
grandparents it was great great
grandparents on one side but mostly
great grandparents uh and my
great-grandparents had it better and my
grandparents had it better and my
parents had it better and I've had it
pretty good and my siblings have it
pretty good and I want these kids to
have it pretty good and it's it's the
it's that belief in Freedom and that the
experiment can work and why do we why do
we want to conserve things from the past
well I have I have this child
that I want to conserve those things so
I can send him off into the future doing
well
um but I'm really looking forward to
when he can play basketball that's the
main thing I've carried him out on the
basketball court a couple times uh can't
dribble yet there's we can dribble but
but no dribbling of a basketball and uh
you know it's uh it's good it's good
Lloyd do you think Twitter will double
down on censoring now that it looks like
Elon is walking away yeah Twitter is an
absolute disaster the censorship there
is insane it's also being ramped up as I
talked about yesterday YouTube has
gotten completely insane also so I hope
that many of you are watching on Rumble
right now and I know our Rumble live
stream views have been very good lately
so I hope that that'll continue but yeah
elon's not going to buy the thing
there's there's no way it's very
disappointing because I think there was
a chance for something amazing to happen
but I think at this point it's like you
know what you can want something you can
fight for something and then and then at
some point
hey reality smacks in the face you gotta
let it go he was willing to buy it at
five percent of the traction was fake it
might be 80 but it's probably at least
50 percent and the shadow Banning and
all of the stuff and it's also not fun
anymore that's the other thing Twitter
used to be fun like there was this cool
thing you could meet people either that
you liked or admired or athletes you
could they had funny little hashtag
games like there was a fun thing there
and now it's just like it's an endless
misery machine so I haven't left it all
together and every now and again I'll
still open it during the day but I'm
doing it way way less and uh we even
created just just to show you the level
that these things infiltrate your lives
the other day I had Phoenix uh create an
alternate Twitter account so that I
could just follow a few things that help
us give get clips for this show so that
instead of me having to be on Twitter
where I'm scrolling and interacting and
seeing all the nonsense we were like
let's just what are the 20 accounts that
are the best things to follow so that I
don't have to pay much attention to the
noise but just get the the factual stuff
that I want to cover on this show so
that's the direction we're going with
all this but no I don't think it's going
to get better at this point uh Jenna
says how's Clyde been with the new baby
Edition and the changes that come with
it Clyde has been amazing and we were
worried about that I told you since he
got down here to Florida the lizards and
the iguanas and the frogs and the snakes
he's been nuts and then we got him
retrained he's been way better but we
brought him into the house and for a few
days before the baby uh came you know we
put some baby clothes around we wanted
to have him to have a distinction
between baby clothes and baby toys and
stuffed animals between the baby stuff
and his stuff so we were trying to do a
little bit of that he has been really
great like if we put Justin in the
dockatot it's the little sort of
portable baby holder that you put on the
couch we can put it on the couch Kyle go
right up next to him getting a little
ball just kind of look at him if he
starts crying Clyde will kind of look at
him see what he can do if he's in his
bedroom and he's crying clydal kind of
give us a signal as if we can't hear it
too he's been really great but of course
all that being said you have to be
careful to some degree I'm not concerned
that he would ever maliciously do
something violent but he is still a
young dog three three and a half years
old he gets super excited he gets the
the Zoomies The Crazies so you don't
want him to jump on him or accidentally
whatever but he's been really really
great so that's been uh that's been
great we'll see when baby two comes
maybe Clyde's lack of attention he'll
start snapping uh Pratt says with Biden
as just the figurehead who exactly is
running the show it seems to be too
carefully coordinated to not have
someone at the top who is it well
you know we talk about this a lot I
don't know is it the Obama machine is it
the Hillary machine is it some
combination of that is it something else
we don't fully understand is it the
world economic forum is it Cloud Schwab
it's something it's something and we all
know it's something but we don't know
what it is but that's why I keep telling
you when when Biden does these divisive
speeches when they put him with the
ridiculous Optics of that red background
you must know that it is intentional so
I see all of these people who keep
falling for it I mean usually you know
conservative people they'll be like
Biden gave his worst speech ever didn't
they know and how does it how did they
not prepare for the Optics of that it's
like they're doing it intentionally they
are trying to scare you and manipulate
you and use double speak so on one so
literally from sentence to sentence buy
it and I want to be the president for
everybody and a peaceful tolerant
America and blah blah blah and then the
next sentence these Mega Republicans are
ruining democracy and should not be part
of civil disc ours it's by Design he's
just the buffoon the the plastic person
that they put up there to repeat the
stuff so I don't know who it is that's a
very weird thing to say right like it's
it's not uh take no pleasure in that I
wish I knew who was really in charge and
and then just compare that say when
Trump was president
you may have hated Trump as a person you
may have not liked Trump's policies but
you knew they were coming from Trump
right you knew that Trump was up there
saying what he thought and that I think
that that's an extremely important part
of the presidency whether you agree with
them or not especially in a world that
feels very post-truth and that fact
Checkers are partisan and all that it's
like you need to basically believe that
the president of the United States
within within certain parameters you
have a basic sense of who he is Donald
Trump you had a basic sense of who he
was and was he a braggard and over the
top and an exaggerator of course all
those things but did you feel like he
loved America that he didn't care what
someone's skin color was he wanted
everyone to succeed all like from my
perspective of course the answer to that
is yes Joe Biden it's like what can you
what can anyone maybe we should get find
somebody who let's get somebody on who's
a real Biden supporter I I don't know
who that is besides Dr Jill Biden it's
like but what what does Joe Biden
actually believe does he fundamentally
believe America is good does he I don't
know I mean he's ushering in all of the
the woke nonsense so does he
um you know what what is it that Joe
Biden believes in that he has not
reversed himself on and it's not
reversed himself because he evolves on
but it's just because he just wants more
power now I don't know so I I would love
to know what's really going on there but
I think at the minimum that's what you
need from a president a president is
someone everyone has to look to and be
like oh I have a basic understanding of
of how he views the world right and then
maybe he's going to fall short on those
things maybe he's not going to get a lot
of those things accomplished but I
basically believe that that I basically
believe that he believes a set of ideas
without that I don't know what you have
and that's what you have with Joe Biden
Stephen says when do you think you'll be
heading back out on the road for a
stand-up or speaking tour it's going to
be a little bit I think maybe next
spring obviously I've wanted to be home
for the last couple weeks with Justin
and baby twos on the way so we sort of
felt then I discussed it with my guys
but like this fall into into Christmas
into the new year it'll be like we'll be
here basically I have a couple gigs like
little one-off things and a few things
throughout Florida and then I've got the
LA thing with uh with Mar but like
basically let's just kind of stay home
and and get settled you know we moved to
Florida we did all this construction
this is the first time now in the last
few weeks that kind of we're back to
normal with a kitchen we're cooking
again like all of those things
um so I think maybe in the spring we'll
do like well maybe like a two-week tour
or something like that something kind of
quick and I still want to do the Europe
thing you know we we had a huge European
tour planned for don't burn this book
the first book that obviously got canned
because of kovid and then I just didn't
have enough time for the don't burn this
country tour to do the Europe thing
because the book came out in April uh I
needed a little bit of time to be home
for the baby and blah blah blah so uh
stay tuned stay tuned uh Paula says what
do you think about the theory that Biden
is egging on the Republicans in hopes
that they'll retaliate with violence I
think there's something there I think
and that's what I mean by these speeches
are by Design when he says one thing
that sounds peaceful and laudatory and
loving and coalescing and then the next
sentence is sort of psychotic and and
and really hitler-esque it really is the
language that he's using the other ring
that he's using it's far worse than
anything Donald Trump was saying
um
so do I think it's sort of intentional
to provoke some kind of response from
Republicans yeah because the more that
they can provoke Republicans and the
more that they can get Republicans to
say crazy things what will the media do
it'll suppress the crazy things that the
Democrats say and it'll inflate the
crazy things that the Republicans say
that would be a pretty clever thing to
do say I don't know a month two months
two days before uh big elections are
coming up these these midterms so yeah
you can't put anything past these guys
but that's always why you give the devil
his due you cannot just say okay they're
Hypocrites you cannot just say okay
they're buffoons and they're idiots and
they don't know what they're doing you
have to acknowledge it that something
whether it whether you like it or not
they got us to this place and until we
readjust how we respond to them which is
obviously what I'm trying to get us all
to do here and what I'm doing in my own
life that's why I moved companies and
and my life to Florida and like you have
some chance in in your life to separate
from these people the the most as most
as possible as much as possible and
that's what you got to do uh we will
have a cold close for you in just a
moment a reminder you can always join us
on the live chat during the show at
reubenreport.locals.com part two of my
interview uh with Donald Trump's
son-in-law and advisor Jared Kushner is
up on Rumble and YouTube right now the
full thing is up absolutely ad-free over
at locals uh and tomorrow the panel
returns uh old guests old old time OG
Reuben report guests Spencer Clayman
Robert Barnes and Amela ekanobi will be
on the show and it'll be a good one I'm
looking forward to just mixing it up
again and uh I think that all I've got
to say about that see you tomorrow
it's in August the
10 000 million jobs since President
Biden took office which is the fastest
job growth in history so you're asking
me where is the success here it is wait
let me finish wait wait hold on